dozens of major corporations as a result
of trump's
tax bill paid nothing in federal taxes
what you don't say is that everybody
paid less in taxes than they did under
obama or they would under you you piece
of [ __ ] but i bet you're paying more
than you thought
what are you saying you thought you were
gonna get a bigger price break screw you
i wanted to get into the top socialist
lies top five
myths that people would do um i i guess
these just continually let's just start
with this bernie sanders
town hall at fox news it personified
everything wrong
with the left wing let's start with this
uh
i happen to believe joe that we have an
absurd
tax system and while millions of people
today
are paying actually more in taxes than
they anticipated
amazon netflix and dozens of major
corporations as a result
of trump's tax bill paid nothing
in federal taxes i think that's a
disgrace what you don't say is that
everybody paid less in taxes than they
did under obama or they would under you
you piece of [ __ ]
by the way do you notice he said dozens
of corporations
just run a quick search and see how many
corporations there are in the united
states
hint it's a lot more than dozens if we
missed a couple of dozen that's okay
they're paying
for one dishonesty they're paying more
than they expected because they wanted
an even
bigger tax cut that you and the media
deceived them to thinking they wouldn't
even get
even the new york times did an expose on
this many people who got a tax cut
didn't actually believe that they got
one at all
most people saved money paid less in
taxes this year
the middle class benefited from the tax
cut everyone did but i bet you're paying
more than you thought
what are you saying you thought you were
gonna get a bigger price break screw you
this is how socialism works it deceives
people into thinking they're worse off
than they are by lying to them and then
using that misery to get elected
promising to solve everyone's problem
with
free money and this was we'll get to the
top five
i think the biggest myths the most
pervasive myths all this was reiterated
there was an article this week
announcing means dot tv did you see it's
an online socialist media network who
without a hint of irony will be a
it'll be a paid subscription service
stephen that's a text so i went to their
site to see what they were about and
again let me know which socialist
candidate you want us to live stream
next week starting at uh
8 pm eastern sanders harris klobuchar
butt gig warren um went to their site
means tv to see what they're no
surprises
i felt like this segment was long
overdue let's cycle through the top five
all right let's get to it
number five is that there is no class
mobility the cards are stacked against
you this comes
directly from the new paid subscription
socialist network
you only really have like so many
positions you can go to the factory
you can go to the college or you can go
to the army
what do i have to do so i can get into a
position to where i can
change what i want to chase versus
surviving
what what oh i feel like i have no
options and you proceed to name
all the options three unbelievable
options by the way the offshoots from
those three options are probably at
least
3 000 options like i could work at a
factory
and work your way up to vice president
work your factory this was in detroit
this network where a uaw worker cost the
company average of over 130
000 a year whoa i'm going to the
military well you can get
tuition paid for work your way up to i
don't know officer not to mention serve
your country
oh i got to go to college and choose any
of the hundreds of degrees available
there
this is like i only got three options i
can't do anything why are you
complaining
horrible because the options i got are
only uh
infinity i don't understand
there's three options to on-ramps
basically they're three on-ramps to any
option you want
for the rest of your life i okay this is
this idea that there is no social
mobility in the united states the cars
are stacked against you
over the course of their lives 56 of
americans will find themselves in the
top 10
73 will spend at least more than a year
in the top 20
okay so this idea that there's a static
99 and top 1
ruling class it's just not true
particularly in the united states and
this brings me to myth number four that
capitalism only benefits the wealthy
uh we hear this all the time that
america sure is a rich country but
for most people it's terrible my mom
actually told me like moving to
america just like made everything worse
from where i feel like money is the
problem i am the solution at the same
time
are you high right now you seem to be
just doing worse or worse
and nobody really seems to be able to do
anything better and better
you know why do our parents work all the
time and then it's still hard for us
to spend too much a system in place that
keeps us there
and to find out about that system like
it's only 9.99 a month
i buy your cars i buy your car
they're not going to stay poor for long
honestly here's the no system is perfect
but namely any system throughout the
history of mankind that has pulled more
people out of poverty
than the free enterprise in a capitalist
system venezuela they killed there you
go you know what here
let's do a mental exercise everyone
watching everyone watching pick a system
any system right now think of it in your
head okay
no that's the answer let's just go
under trump because they try to they try
to amplify this with donald trump people
are worse off ever
we have the lowest unemployment rate in
50 years record numbers of workers
returning to the workforce
highest job labor force participation
rate and by the way even with all that
we actually have
both the lowest layoff rate and the
highest amount of unfulfilled meaning
available jobs
since the department of labor began
recording the statistics
ever it's time to toss your hemp noose
over the basement pipe
because i only got three options college
military or being an entrepreneur
it's like i could go to school study and
maybe like the stem field or get our
shark tank what the [ __ ] like
we need a new system right uh hit the
notification bell by the way join up at
lots of clutter.com
club it's more necessary than ever uh
half eastern lawyer bill richmond can
tell you of course subscribe capitals
and um hit the
hit the notification bell i already said
that and ran this on itunes it doesn't
really matter
here's one of the biggest ones you've
heard this a lot right the idea that
there's there's no wage growth
one of the most common myths is that
wages have remained the same
if you factor in inflation and you look
at us where people are working more but
they're not getting paid any more money
here you go you hear it all the time and
about half of americans
don't own a stock a mutual fund
it means nothing to them so they'd
rather get a wage increase
for quite a while it doesn't seem to be
moving too much is wage or wages
yeah two percent the trouble with two
percent is two percent kind of just
sucks
wages that is not enough to make anyone
feel the job market boom
first if i don't want to go ad hominem
but is her chin penciled on
it's like the burger meister meiber has
two very defined lines
okay this is just as uh problematic to
use their word as the wage gap the idea
of 77 cents in the dollar that just
compares women
make x men make why one problem with
computing wage growth the way that the
bureau of labor
the statistics do is they they do
average hourly earnings it's gonna get a
little nerdy let me try and go through
this really quickly
that doesn't take into account lifetime
wage growth i highly recommend
you check out the sources in the overlay
that we bring up here right now let me
distill it for you when you take into
account individual wage growth is
calculated by the census
their current population survey okay
those models it's actually closer to
five percent
average doesn't suck no average
individual wage growth is always higher
than the simple
average hourly earnings growth and
there's there are a few reasons for this
and i want you to do your own mental
exercise because anecdotal obviously
doesn't necessarily prove a point
but the empirical data i believe will
match up with your anecdotal
experience so anyone out there right now
who's done
a job or been in a career in the same
field of work for more than 10 years
watching right now okay i'd like you to
comment below
if you have been doing the same job or
working with the same company same field
of work for 10 years
i want you to do some math have you only
seen a two percent wage growth
i i i i would no challenge anyone out
there
couple lower earners at the beginning of
their life by the way they tend to have
the most
wage growth as people get older they get
wealthier the percentage of
wage growth is less so if you're seeing
that sort of pay bump bottom out a
little bit that now it maybe used to be
10
12 now it's 2 that means you're probably
being paid pretty well if it's over a
lifetime
yeah exactly by the way on top of that
wage growth just hit a 10-year high
despite all the models breaking the
exact opposite uh and it seems like it's
likely to keep accelerating all right
listed frankly so much weight you're
gonna be so tired of all the growth not
your wages you won't have room
your your wages will have stretch marks
okay
here's a second lie it's just it's
really stupid but i'm going to point out
why i think you'll realize it's stupid
on its face but you often don't think of
it this way that wealth inequality
is a huge problem we want to deal with
the grotesque level of income and wealth
inequality in america
very few people think it is acceptable
or moral that the top
one tenth of one percent owns almost as
much wealth as the bottom
90 percent here's what i call a stupid
exercise
[Laughter]
if i doubled every single person right
now watching listening doubled
all of our incomes tomorrow every single
one wealth inequality would increase
would you be pissed would you prefer to
live in a place like
cuba or venezuela where people make
whopping 30
a month in cuba the problem isn't
poverty the problem is wealth inequality
and i know that there are some nations
in between i'm not saying your only
choice is the united states or cuba
generally speaking
socialism simply socializes mediocrity
poverty
matter of fact every study that we have
available shows there's no correlation
between wealth inequality
and the poverty rate usually as wealth
inequality becomes
big as that gap becomes bigger
conditions of poor families have
actually improved and here's here's you
know it's not so much a lie that they uh
they push the here's the let me set this
up with a fact
socialism has never actually worked okay
and they always try to claim that it's
never been tried
properly or where it has been tried
properly now they've pivoted this is
only the last 10 years to the
scandinavian countries that they're all
socialists here you go
what happened in venezuela they call
that democratic socialism
but it looks like he's masturbating on a
subway the problem is though brothers at
any time there's been
the attempts of ordinary people to
engage in self-determination
they can get crushed by external nation
look at u.s policies toward venezuela
has been
very very ugly nicaragua in the same way
so we've never had a chance to really
pull it off so it's only been a movement
so far well so long as we know what
democratic socialism
and if we know that in countries in
scandinavia like denmark norway sweden
they are very democratic countries
obviously america will look more like
scandinavia that's right
that's right and what's wrong with that
uh
well there's a lot wrong with that
first off the snuffs the snuffs the
snooze
the snooze snooze tobacco goes up your
nose oh no nevermind that's
enough no no it's not flows in your lip
goes up your nose news goes here snuff
goes here i don't know anything about uh
tobacco outside of cigars which by the
way ironically come from a lot of these
craphole countries oh they trick nickel
that's the one silver lining
they try to say venezuela a truly
socialist and by the way
oil rich country kind of starting on
phase three
only failed because of u.s policies
through the scandinavia we did a whole
segment on this so i'm just going to
sort of brush on this scandinavian
countries actually they built up their
wealth under free market
economies and right now they're actually
moving much more toward free market
capitalism
uh despite they're incredibly small
homogenous populations by the way
and keep in mind their top corporate tax
rates actually lower than the united
states were under obama we're actually
going their direction now finally for
the first time
and something else that is remarkable to
me did you know that when scandinavian
people move to the united states they
have higher standards of living on
average than those in the scandinavian
countries in other words danes in the
united states have it better than danes
in denmark
swedes of the united states have it
better than swedes in sweden
without the high suicide rate without
their surprise
well i know japan but i think norway
norway yeah that's just because of the
weather and they all have to watch let
the right one in yeah and by the way how
many times do they have to come on
camera and say bernie please stop
pointing to us as socialists yeah
we're not socialists they have a lot of
they have a social safety net which by
the way is why cars for example most
uh i think in denmark most people can't
afford used cars you can go to lot of
credit.com we wrote an article about
this not long ago because the taxes are
unbelievable
yeah there's a huge burden on the middle
class that being said they built up
their wealth
under free market economies so you can't
claim that a country if the united
states for example tomorrow
the united states tomorrow became a
socialist country would you say that we
became the world's greatest superpower
under socialism no of course not no
obviously i would say that the facts are
on our side okay because i just listed
over a dozen
but i know that both sides argue they're
on the side of truth okay let's put that
aside for a second
one thing that can't be denied is that
even in theory
capitalist free enterprises the
conservative worldview can only function
if an individual feels
empowered and i know that bernie bros
are going to say that that's a lie
because of the system man all right i
know i know the fact is that the
conservative message
is predicated on the idea that
individuals feel optimistic
about their opportunities in future
socialists can only remain in power by
convincing the entire population
of hopelessness conservatives have to
campaign on hey
anyone can make it in america you're
good enough democrats and socialists
half but i repeat myself have to
campaign on you can't make it you're not
good enough
others are going to win you'll lose and
none of it is in your control because
it's all a part of the system
it is a selfish appeal and certainly
right now in the united states
it's not based on truth right now in an
economy with the lowest unemployment
highest job participation least amount
of firings most amount of jobs available
in decades
they're still selling you propaganda
that you couldn't possibly make it
without them and i'll come out and say
it
in 2019 only the weakest among you
by that lie if you look at all of the
prospects i just listed
out there and feel you don't feel
hopeful in any way
there's there's no hope for you you lost
hope long before you made that walk to
the ballot box
that's my biggest problem with socialism
hey there if you like this video
subscribe
or click one of these videos playing in
a box you know what
hit the notification bell because
subscriptions don't really mean anything
anymore
especially if you're not 18 or older at
the very least logged into youtube as 18
or older because sometimes people are 25
but they don't know how to use the
youtube system properly and then you
never just hit the notification bell
or you hate yourself